exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deceive me now is
because those magic in
I can see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from playground games
Ralf Fulton
[Applause]
thank you so much it is fantastic to be
here today I am excited to show you the
world premiere of Forza horizon for set
a beautiful historic Britain Forza
horizon 4 features dynamic seasons in a
shared open-world and seasons change
everything let me introduce you to some
of our team who will be helping them
with the game today
please welcome bill who is online with a
few friends in the beautiful English
countryside he has chosen the incredible
new McLaren Senna and say hi to Solomon
who is hanging out with his buddies on
the streets of Scotland's capital
Edinburgh Sullivan is driving the
hoonigan Ford Focus and please welcome
Andy whose off-road buggy is perfect for
taking jumps scaling rocky terrain and
having fun on the coastline of Breton
but first let's join Rebecca she is
enjoying the summer and her highly
customized Nissan Silvia
the Sun is 8 the sky is blue and it's
the perfect day for a drive for
summarize enforce Britain is a shared
open world when you play you play with
the entire community and that means the
other driver shall meets in the game
will be real people with all the variety
and spontaneity and fun that real people
bring flesh join Bell he's in the same
shared world is Rebecca driving at
speeds made even more thrilling on Xbox
one X by the brand's new 60 FPS mode
meanwhile Andy is bouncing around the
djinns nearby
as you can see horizon for is still full
of action-packed fun and now we're going
to show you how seasons change
everything
[Applause]
and horizon for every season changes the
world around you with each bringing its
own unique beauty and unique gameplay
one of the great things about this
shared world is that it's easy to
interact with the people you meet here
Solomon and Rebecca used the new quick
chat feature on the d-pad to start a new
friendship at Luke's leg Rebecca has
found some like-minded friends
[Music]
it's great to play solo but it's better
to play with others horizon for lets you
seamlessly enter core from within the
game worlds
seasons time of day and weather
conditions are dynamic but they are
synchronized for every player so the
entire community will experience them at
the same time
[Applause]
now as much as we'd all love to sit and
watch the Sun go down together let's see
how this scene Luke's in winter
the entire open world changes beyond
recognition in winter the lake has
frozen solids and previously
inaccessible areas can be reached the
trees and entirely lost their leaves and
snow and ice covered the terrain the
visuals and the driving experience
couldn't be more different and now a
blimp has appeared over the ice to
signal the start of a new world event
Forsyth unlive invites the entire
community to come together and cooperate
to win big rewards and while they head
off to the event I'd like to show you
how the world of forts on horizon for
Luke's and spring
once again the world changes completely
with the seasons bringing new driving
experiences new gameplay a new events
across the whole world every season
there are new reasons to play Forza
horizon 4 and the huge creative
fun-loving horizon community will be
there to enjoy them with you
today you've seen a completely new take
on horizon and force a horizon for you
will live in a vast beautiful world in
which dynamic seasons change everything
Forza horizon 4 is coming to Xbox one on
Windows 10 on October 2nd and I am
thrilled to announce that it will be
included in Xbox game pass on the same
day thank you so much please welcome
back bill Spencer
[Applause]